part two of the absolute worst roommate  i have ever had and how we got him to  move out when i lived with him there  were weeks where i met five different  girls in one week every day our kitchen  would be used because he was having like  a dinner with them after he would hook  up with them and it would be so  loud and i'm talking to the point like  it was just disrespectful like i should  not  there were noises there were noises the  last straw was when he threw a party  while we were sleeping i used to have to  get up at 5am for basketball so i'd fall  asleep at like nine o'clock at night and  one day i wake up at like two in the  morning to blaring music and all of  these people in my apartment crazy thing  was it was like a tuesday it was a  weekday my roommate and i ended up  calling the cops on our own house to get  these people out of here knew we had to  get rid of that roommate we couldn't  live like this anymore like for part  three